hey guys Pete here today we're going to
look at some of the questions that I got
in the comments in my twin peaks' season
3 parts 1 & 2 recap and review if you
haven't seen that I'll put a link here
you can go check that out it answers a
lot of questions in and of it so but we
got some good ones and we didn't get a
lot but in doing this hopefully you guys
will put more questions in the comments
so that we can do this on a weekly basis
once the show gets into that cycle so
the first and most repeated question was
Phillip Gerard is not Phillip Jeffries
or something like that posed as a
question or you know yeah this was a
total mistake on my part when I was
looking at the credits to see if Jacques
Renault was listed I saw a Phillip
Gerard and mix that up with Phillip
Jeffries probably jumped out to me
because I'm used to calling Mike so
Michael Gerard but whatever how I
managed not to put two and two together
when I saw it was out Strobel is a
mystery and it was plain and simple a
mistake so that's that sorry
next question I was completely baffled
by the new arm what in the world was
that the actor who played the arm glass
the man from another place was supposed
to reprise his role I believe he even
came in to start shooting his scenes but
then may have been difficult to work
with something along those lines one way
or another he ended up not being
involved in season 3 so the character
had to be reimagined how it became a
tree we can't say for sure but the next
couple of questions are related to the
arm as well so maybe that'll help paint
a picture of what's up with this
character did anyone else notice a
similarity between the new arm and the
mutant baby and Eraserhead now when I
first read this I remember I remember
the baby looking like et or a lot like
et from it's been a while since I'd seen
Eraserhead
but yeah when I went back and look if we
compare the two there is a definite
resemblance twin peaks the return is
full of Easter eggs or callbacks to both
the original run and Lynch's other work
like way too many to get into here but
if you check out the comment people have
been pointing them out left and right so
does anyone else think being in the box
could be the arms doppelganger actually
quite a lot of people view in my video
about the box I mentioned that is one of
the likely explanations now the video
was about the Box not the creature but
some people have made that connection
others are leaning towards it the fact
that it might be Laura based largely on
the fact that she flew away in front of
Cooper in the Red Room truth is we don't
know for sure or if it is the mother
that we hear about in the machine room
check out my video about the glass box
for more info on that and I will link
that in the endcard of this video but
either way the head of the creature
bears a definite resemblance to the
evolved arm and its doppelganger
the next question was could the creature
be Laura the short answer is yes it
could be I don't think there's enough
visual evidence here though and I'm
guessing that we'll probably get a lot
more when we talk about anything being
Laura I think it's important to keep in
mind quite a few things but I mean first
of all we have doppelgangers and we have
no real idea what Laura is right now I
mean we know real-life Laura was killed
and she slipped on the ring in an
attempt to prevent Bob from taking
control of her in the real world that's
what we know we have seen her in the Red
Room but that doesn't really explain
much especially considering in the most
recent scene she took off her face to
reveal she was filled with light and
then she flew away in a way that was
looked very uncomfortable or at least
she was screaming all that means what I
mean yeah lowers she's still a mystery
her status is still a total mystery at
this point so if you're saying that
somebody might be Laura what exactly
does that mean I'm sure we're going to
find out more though on that as well why
didn't the camera catch cooper passing
through the glass box this question has
come up a couple of times on this video
and a different one and unless
there's something I don't think we know
that he didn't exactly now this gets
into Episode three some but I'm going to
try not to spoil everything my
understanding is that the FBI is
currently investigating the murder of
Santa Tracy which means they have all
that digital you know eligible images
and recordings from those cameras Tammy
gave Gordon and Albert an update on the
crime scene saying that from time to
time shapes move through the box but
they only show up for a few frames so I
don't think that's definitive in that it
didn't catch Cooper to me that means
that something it caught something and
it does catch something but they can't
necessarily make out what it is yet
now we saw Cooper clearly any kind of
sort of lazily pass through the box in
our eyes but that doesn't mean that time
I mean time is completely subjective or
I went to a little subjective isn't the
right word but we don't really know how
time was passing right then does that
make sense so I don't want to get too
much into any more of that because
that's in the next episode but I don't
think the bottom line is I don't think
that we know that the FBI won't be able
to recover or see something until you
know we learn more about it what's the
figure in the cell the woodsman who we
see in the room about the convenience
store on this I'll just put the photos
up here side-by-side for comparison and
you guys tell me I mean this is a
character that comes to mind right away
for a lot of people myself included but
the character in the cell that appears
to be covered in oil doesn't exactly
have the beard woodsman Han and I read
someone said that he's wearing Buffalo
plaid which is a lumberjack thing but I
can't tell personally so I don't know I
don't think we know for sure it would be
very interesting if this was the case
and maybe then we would even find out if
the lumberjack or woodsman is the log
lady's husband or not right now I don't
think we can say for sure since the guy
seems to be covered in oil which turns
out to be a really good way to obscure
who it is I mean if you look I've looked
at it doom then lightened up all these
different things
and what you see is a black figure with
their bright white eyes is about it do
you think there's a connection between
this series and the secret history
absolutely I don't think there's any
question I mean without a doubt what it
is isn't necessarily so easy to come up
and say well this is the connection but
I think in the end the secret history
and frost next book that he announced
the final dossier those will be
companions to this series like I guess
you know I'm thinking that the secret
history points us towards things to
think about in relation to what we're
about to see in this run rather than
filling in the blanks from the original
run other words yeah it gives us a
little bit of background and whatnot but
I don't think it's to make the original
series more clear I think that you know
it's it was written with this in mind
and there's a lot of controversy about
things being changed and whatnot and I
don't have an answer about any of that
I'm actually been working on a video
about the secret history but yeah the
fact that they that he mentioned that
there'll be another book that's going to
come out afterwards just going to fill
in the blanks which might have had I
mean they said originally that the
secret history would fill in the blank
so I think that it's all connected
with season 3 so those are the questions
I picked out from you guys I mentioned
some of my questions at the end of the
recap and review some other ones that
have popped up are is could that
possibly be major Briggs body that's in
the broom connected or not connected
into a disconnected from the head of
Ruth Davenport and another thing that's
come to mind sort of after the fact is
Haq went to glass and berry Grove
because there was an event about to go
down he was essentially standing at the
portal to the Red Room and then the next
time we see him he's just chilling with
Andy and Lucy looking over the evidence
again so did he see something or did
anything happen or you know I mean it's
kind of weird that I haven't seen
anybody really talking about it and I
don't know if I missed something but
yeah I've been wondering about hawk-like
let's talk up too and did he see
anything that he would be able to enter
was he afraid to enter hopefully we'll
find out more about
that as well are the two people sitting
in the back of the room whenever he's
with Otis and Beulah Lodge spirits there
seems to be something going on with
those guys one small ones big seems a
little bit different compared to you
know Rey and dari I don't think our and
Otis doesn't appear to be beulah might I
mean she's a little bit more imposing
and seems to be in charge but I think
there's a possibility that those two
might be some kind of important
characters and that the eight the card
that evil coupe shows Daria before he
kills her what do you guys think about
this symbol I mean it kind of looks like
the owl glyph you know the symbol that's
on the ring that we see over and over
again except it's obviously altered so
as far as video releases go I have to
get out the episode for recap and review
I will be doing a Q&A on both that and
episode 3 or part 3 whatever you want to
call it so if you have questions about
either one of those episodes put them in
the comments unless your question in
relation to episode 3 is why I'm so
stupid and know absolutely nothing about
David Lynch because I've gotten that one
already a bunch and I will address that
but yeah if you have anything about the
scale go ahead and leave it there and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon